so the last time I saw you was at New
Year's Eve in Niagara Falls it was
freezing cold
yes 60,000 people out there enjoying
your performance it's almost like you
like the cold is that what's going on
you love a lot of the times we come up
it's a bit chilly yeah is it hard to
perform outside when is that cold yeah
as a guitar player it is yeah definitely
I mean cuz you know if you're singing
like Nick Jonas was that night you can
put gloves on but it's fit hoplite
doesn't work with any issues with your
vocals when you're doing that outside a
little bit yeah yeah yeah and so here
you are at the Grey Cup for one of the
biggest events that are happening yeah
Super Bowl right yeah how do you prepare
the music that you're gonna perform in
that short timeframe to make sure the
fans are excited yeah well I mean my
thing was to try and keep it up
predominantly up-tempo because it's you
know it is the great yeah and keep
everybody yeah and a lot of familiarity
hopefully too which has a few songs to
strain to get about a 12 and a half
minute medley yeah it's a one song
particularly that you had to have part
of it I think everybody would ask that
different for usually we've covered
everybody I love them all for different
reasons yeah it's football a big thing
at home for you do you like watching
football do you play
CFL is new to mate yeah so I know I'm a
little bit a little bit about NFL but
yeah it's it's that I'm being thrown
into it here getting totally familiar
with the teams and this field which is a
little bit bigger I think that NFL
that's right that's what makes us so
much better yeah and you also prepared
by watching some footage from old
performances with Shania Twain yeah did
you get any tips from their performances
I think medleys the way to go usually
not a fan of medleys winter saying okay
yeah I've resisted them always over the
years but when you get a situation like
this it's it's kind of the most obvious
thing to do instead of doing two songs
or three songs yeah
now you've been really busy you just
came off a tour you're going on another
tour starting at December in Australia
and yeah you're also going to be in
Vegas next year yeah it's a lot and I
can see how much you appreciate your
fans by doing that
so hey what does it mean for you to be
on the road that long well I mean I'm in
a now it sounds like a lot but I mean
I'm lonely too are we gonna play shows
and then I come home and I go play
shares or come home so I'm not gone for
weeks and weeks at a time is it ever
hard for you to be on the road I love it
you love it yeah I've always loved it
yeah I love playing live and tomorrow
I'm so looking forward to yeah we're
looking forward to it too that you're
here in Canada women break up and you're
having hits by hits by hits you have
right now we were which is number one
now in Canada
oh not congratulations thank you very
much what does it mean for you to be
able to continue to make music that
people absolutely love I mean I love
making music I've been making it if I
was playing some little club on the
corner of Broadway you know but I feel
very blessed that I get to do it at the
level I get to do it at how's the new
album going it's coming along
you look really good yeah I've been
working on it for a solid year every
every chance that I thought not on the
right I've been in the studio quite a
bit so yeah give a name for the album I
do we're gonna announce that down the
track yeah hopefully enough you know
when artists make music I always find it
curious to find out when you do
something that's beautiful to you who's
the person you want to share it with
whose opinion matters the most to you
well I mean everybody's different
reasons of course mmm the first one I
want to I want to make sure it's what
I've got in mind when I'm in the studio
you know walking out of the studio with
that record in that my hope would come
together sometimes it's it goes off on a
whole different tangent but I need to be
able to walk out of there feeling really
good about it and then the rest it you
could leave it up yeah today
after that yeah you know the process is
is where I'm involved in is there one
person particular that you like to get
their opinion when you make music you
asking about my wife no I'm not actually
because they'll say they're producers
but it well she gets to hear everything
yeah of course and but they know the
fans the audience they're the ones that
are gonna speak the strongest and
loudest mhm
oh yeah now there's been a lot of
biopics this year with Queen Elton John
Motley Crue's if there was a biopic on
you who would you want to play you I've
no clue no clue no no sure Chris yeah
that's a good one no Chris yeah the last
metal word of choice yeah iWhat somebody
taken Heath Ledger if he was still
around yeah yeah I could see
similarities yeah yeah I like but you
would be totally into doing a biopic
yeah it sounds terrifying at the same
time try trying to get your life into
two hours an impossible task the
holidays are coming up which is very
exciting
yeah and do you have traditions at home
you just released this song as well is
that supposed to be dirty it's not dirty
at all no it's you know it's a sexy song
it's beautiful do you have traditions at
home I don't know about traditions but
just we often go to Australia at
Christmas because it's our parents that
lived there I both their moms are there
it's also a summer which is the nice
time to go there and you have a puppy
that's bascially I'm just trying to hang
on to you now wave you also have a puppy
yes that'll be part of the tradition as
well yeah a new tradition a new
tradition yeah no success everyone has
their own definition of success and
you've had a lot of incredible success
in your life but what has been your own
achievement that you feel has been the
biggest to you
um still getting to do it that the level
I get to do it at and that's really it
that's all I ever wanted to do is keep
making records and hopefully people
wanted to come and see em live you know
I mean that's the baseline of it all and
I still feel that way about other
artists I hear a song and they're in
another song and I so wanna go see them
in concert and I just want to go and be
with everybody and sing that song I feel
the same way depending you know no
matter what side of the stage I'm on
you